La première scène que j'ai conçue :
une énorme boite de lumière avec le nom de sa maison de disque.
Il était triomphalement planté devant, il y avait comme des éclairs.
C'était épique, mais genre débutant.
On est passé à une grande bande de ciel déchirée au milieu,
et à travers la déchirure, vous pouviez voir des parties profondes du cosmos.
Ça se rapproche.
On est passé à debout en haut d'un obélisque,
debout sur un flanc de montagne, debout sur une pile de boites.
Il évoluait en tant qu'artiste dans l'espace,
et c'était mon boulot d'essayer de suivre.
Quand on a fait Coachella,
il se tenait
debout devant un artefact ancien de 24 mètres d'épaisseur et 12 de hauteur,
littéralement donné de Dieu à l'homme.
Il était en train d'évoluer, et on en était tous témoins.
Et dans son dernier show, que je n'ai pas conçu mais que j'ai vu,
il s'était trouvé.
Il était littéralement sur un pont flottant en plexiglas
au-dessus de ses fans,
qui n'avaient pas d'autre choix que de louer Yeezus au-dessus de tout.
(Rires)
Il s'était déifié.
On ne peut pas devenir Yeezus dans notre salon.
L'espace lui a dit qui il était,
et il nous l'a montré.
Quand j'avais 20 ans,
je conduisais dans un parking, et j'ai vu une flaque.
J'ai pensé : « Je vais passer à gauche. Non... Je vais passer dedans. »
Et je suis passé dans la flaque : « pssh », toute l'eau sur ma voiture,
et instantanément, j'ai eu une révélation.
L'ampoule s'allume.
Tout dans le monde a besoin d'être conçu.
Bien sûr, j'ai pensé :
« On a besoin de concevoir l'écoulement du parking. »
Puis je me suis dit : « Tout dans le monde a besoin d'être conçu. »
C'est vrai : si on la laissait faire,
Mère Nature ne va pas vous aider et vous tracer
un chemin intéressant.
J'ai passé ma carrière à chercher dans l'esprit des gens
et à en créer des mondes avec lesquels on peut tous interagir.
Vous ne pourrez peut-être pas le faire avec des collaborateurs,
mais je pense que si vous sortez d'ici, ces trois étapes faciles :
la thérapie, qui je veux être, pourquoi je fais ce que je fais ;
la conception, créer un plan et essayer de le finaliser,
qu'est-ce que je peux faire ;
l’exécution.
Je pense que si vous y ajoutez un peu de la théorie de la couleur,
(Rires)
des idées de design cool et un non-respect général des standards architecturaux,
vous pouvez sortir
et créer le monde dans lequel vous voulez vivre,
et je vais rentrer chez moi et m'acheter une nouvelle poubelle.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)